[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
whole living room so we're in Vegas now
we just got into our room this is so
excited tomorrow is the khabib McGregor
fight we got tickets we are here with
Barton Geo they've just checked into
their room because they are into I know
we could hear them through the wall oh
man it's not that soundproof the feeling
is so frickin far for me it feels so
tiny what that is so cool
we have so much room to walk yeah it's
like we can like you can jog in here
like this is baby nicer room I know
oh my god I'm dizzy now oh yeah that's
like one of them means look at this
closet
this is extravagant day I'm gonna lock
you in there just kidding
you know what sucks they could have not
given them that room and we could have
connected our room maybe someone over
there are no oh wow you can poop in
private while I do my makeup or shower
anyways back to serious talk who do you
got
goodnight or McGregor animal is serious
I'm the defender service sport so I
can't really have an opinion if I'm not
really into a sport but you know the
characters are involved it should part
of the reason why I like this stuff so
much is not because of the fighting part
it's more about like the characters that
these fighters create for themselves and
that's you in your bathroom I just
noticed that yeah it's a part of what I
love about the combat sports world is
the characters that these fighters
create for themselves and McGregor has
done that so beautifully you know I love
it from whatever little that I do know I
really am going for McGregor more
because he just seems like such a
likable guy yeah for better for worse
he's still really like so ballsy that he
decided like yeah I'm gonna you can do
boxing you know fight me whether I'm
like that's so cool like no one has done
that you say they know anything
common knowledge that's why I don't know
but and then like everyone than the fact
that like whatever little you tell me
like how he's been with the same girl
all this time and like true she's like
sticking by his side they were like the
thick and thin it's pretty cool yeah I
really like his story and I don't know
anything about Tuppy himself yeah
very likable story - I like his story
too I just like how he was so like tough
of like with McGregor with the whole
chair and the bus and the years thing if
you won't talk to me come talk to me
I'll give you my place come you know
this okay so given that you finger
burger yeah I would chicken burger true
[Music]
if visitors hola this all I know is that
me so cool be like a slumber party yeah
oh there's a limit I've just realized
that I have like some sort of caffeine
addiction because for the last couple
weeks I've been having headaches like
happy withdrawal headache oh that never
happens to me and I only drink one cup
of coffee as date I've never done for
one in one cup and somehow that has made
me kept independent and now that we're
walking around my head is like pulsating
on my mom and I need a cup of coffee so
that's what we're doing right now we're
on a mission to find a little cafe where
we can just have some desserts and drink
some coffee
oh we got it
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're going pumpkin today we're going
on a pumpkin streak there's a guy recall
I know I do want that pumpkin latte I'm
a basic girl okay I look good stuff but
I don't know about the Comanche state
when they just made one at home
like let me save that pumpkin cheesecake
flavor for when I go back
you're like big pumpkin connoisseur now
I'm not a connoisseur of anything in
life ever of anything
I'm just like I don't know kind of girl
good enough that's how I am - you're
good enough you don't care about my
opinion
are you kidding me I love it I don't
care that I know when turning to save
because I'm
so do I like oatmeal cookies or no do
don't you I do actually think they're my
favorite cookie see I told you I know
you are you gonna get offended over
everything I'm not well I wanted to ask
like if you guys like oh man forget
because I grew up always were loving
them and people always hated them saying
like hey cookies they always like you
pick up what could be think of the
chocolate chip cookie believed by now
that don't realize it's got seen I'm
like yeah I never understood that so
good if y'all of the reason they
actually don't like chocolate chip
cookie dough that much well we wish to
make oatmeal cookies like yes that's
what it is
yeah I remember call my friends going up
and say if you ever want a bite to a
cookie that tastes like a grandma ghetto
feel good reasons are delicious oatmeal
delicious I don't care what anyone says
I don't like walking in public with bar
sometimes honestly you can get away with
it in Vegas because everyone just thinks
he's from really early true-true
now walking towards the t-mobile Arena
because you wanted to check it out see
what it's all about
yeah they're ready we haven't started
drinking in Vegas I can feel like
what are we doing I'm sorry drinking it
because I'm looking for that popper 12
[Music]
excited for you I know this means a lot
to you look at this support tomorrow
alright so we are about to witness some
history tomorrow let's get some
predictions real quick for the fights
part McGregor D put you first McGregor
um could be okay logically could be in
my heart and I'm gonna fall with my
heart McGregor I've been in the Gregor
fan since I heard of him so I'm gonna
just stick with it okay okay one
McGregor why you did ladies first
ah well I said earlier because I just I
really like whatever I know about
McGregor honestly like when he fought
Mayweather he won my heart because like
no one does that
so I'm like I want him to win but
honestly could be looks like a really
kick butt
to McGregor's okay all right what about
you part okay same answer as Geo my
heart says McGregor my brain says could
beep but if I had to put my your house I
just have to say McGregor because I've
seen him pull miracles and he's crafty
and he does this thing like ooh and it's
so fun to watch right I loved it I just
like demon foods yeah he's so slippery
but no it's far too safe
that's three McGregor's I think McGregor
just because I don't know I've been so
back and forth on this my brother's
birthday money I spent the money on the
tickets
oh the tickets are expensive yeah team
arlynn par for 12 not a brandy
with Irish alcohol cheers to everyone
here
fabulous word kidlets Irish err Irish Oh
should I ask them at the head proper
1204 question do you guys by any chance
have proper 12 with you here we will try
before the beginnings what just arrived
proper 12 I'm really excited to drink it
I've been told there's a lot of Elvis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sweet honestly I don't know what I'm
looking for in a Buddha whisky but
well checked off good morning good
morning catching a bad time I don't know
so weird like just i don't know where i
speeded to cause we're about to go have
breakfast and then after breakfast we're
gonna go right ready to eat EUV I am so
ready so exciting
I wasn't so far down there's like a
debutante speed-up it's so fun
[Music]
we're ready for the fight this is the
moment we've been waiting for so we're
gonna go meet Bart enjoy ran down the
hallway and we're gonna have an early
dinner before heading over to the arena
well done media
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ermahgerd fans but an Irish flags
everywhere everything to find out about
McGregor and could be Nirvana made off
and play you have to say is less me
compare bhagavate oh thank you comment
everything before you not laser your
passion and I love it alright so this is
my first UFC fight I've ever been to
it's crazy how many aggressive
everyone's like almost like rate did
throw down or like all the fans are like
if you say [ __ ] problem thing about
carnivore burger
the perfect storm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's
[Applause]
oh my goodness no more we're watching
[Applause]
my hands are shaking man Dylan Danis
[Music]
a runner really high
[Applause]
[Music]
all around you better put that away
someone's gonna jump you it's just
better to be safe than sorry water
trouble people here a lot of angry fans
[Music]